les fleurs et les messages de sympathie
ne cessent d'arriver au domicile de
georges salines depuis qu'il a appris
que sa fille le la partie vendredi pour
un concert au bataclan n'en reviendra
jamais beaucoup passionnément la vie je
crois qu'elle a une très belle vie une
vie trop courte mais elle a une très
bonne nuit avant d'aller à la morgue
pour y reconnaître le corps genre
salines parcouru ces photos de sa fille
pour que ce soit cette image qui demeure
celle de la lola adeptes de roller derby
celle de la voyageuse qui avait étudié
au japon qui avait vécu et travaillé à
montréal mois ci était vraiment une
citoyenne du monde et à travers toute sa
vie elle a été le symbole de cette
ouverture aux autres de se partage entre
les cultures si ce père meurtri a
accepté de nous ouvrir ses portes c'est
parce qu'il voulait lancer un message
malgré le fait qu'on soit vraiment
frapper votre intimité entre cher on ne
souhaite pas du tout s'exprimer sur le
mode 2
de la violence de la revanche de et pour
oeil dent pour dent la meilleure arme de
la france contre le terrorisme selon lui
c'est son ouverture et son respect de
l'eau c'est d'ailleurs une france
multicolore pas seulement bleu blanc
rouge qui s'est rassemblée place de la
république et partout ailleurs au pays
pour une minute de silence à la mémoire
des victimes
une nation entière à l'arrêt en
communion c'est quelque chose qui vient
du coeur j'aurais pu ne pas venir c'est
quelque chose qui était naturel pour moi
et quand je vois tout ce monde qui ici à
ce recueil fut d'autant plus fiers
d'appartenir à ce pays à saint jean
c'est la première fois que les français
se réunissent en si grand nombre au même
endroit depuis les attentats de vendredi
la première fois qu ils bravent les
consigne de rester chez eux et
l'interdiction de se rassembler le
besoin de se retrouver ensemble
solidaire était plus fort que toi de
toutes origines
ils se sont rassemblés spontanément
autour de ce piano ambulant pour chanter
en choeur un grand classique du canadien
leonard cohen
ils sont venus de partout aussi pour
donner du sang comme ici à la mairie de
vincennes où ils étaient plus d'une
centaine mus par le désir pressant de
faire quelque chose
une collecte de sang victime de son
succès c'est du bon sens tu vomis tout
soit fait pour autant s'être donné son
sang un geste chargé de sens que si m
amazon a posé pour la première fois de
sa vie
donc pour moi c'était important de faire
au moins ça c'est quelque chose que je
peux faire toutes façons donc c'est vrai
j'étais vraiment très choqué ça m'a
vraiment beaucoup toucher quoi et
surtout en tant que musulmane en fait ça
donne ça dégage se dégage une image de
nous qui est face à du tout quoi à
l'extérieur la mairie arborait fièrement
ses couleurs le bleu le blanc et le
rouge tout comme la tour eiffel un
symbole un message la france face à
l'horreur reste debout
et si jean françois bélanger
radio-canada paris